- OF THE TORCH.
- YEAH.
THIS IS THE GIST.
HOLD ON.
- [laughs]
- THIS IS THE GIST
OF THE ARM, RIGHT?
IF YOU CARE ABOUT AMERICA,
YOU'LL SEE THIS
FOR WHAT IT'S MEANT TO BE.
- THE SMURF DICK.
[laughs]
- ALL RIGHT.
HELLO.
TODAY WE'RE GONNA STALK ABOUT
THE STATUE OF LIVER--[chuckles]
LIBERTY.
WE HAVE THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
TODAY BECAUSE OF A MAN NAMED
FREDERIC BARTHOLDI,
A SCULPTOR IN FRANCE.
ONE DAY HE WAS SITTING DOWN
WITH HIS BUDDY WHO WAS LIKE,
HEY, IT'S 1865.
THE UNITED STATES IS TURNING
100 [bleep] YEARS OLD.
SOMEONE'S GONNA GIVE THEM A GIFT
FOR THEIR 100TH BIRTHDAY.
IT SHOULD BE FRANCE.
AND BARTHOLDI'S LIKE,
[bleep] YEAH.
THIS SOUNDS [bleep] AMAZING.
YEAH.
AND BARTHOLDI COMES UP
WITH THIS IDEA OF THIS GIANT
300-FOOT STATUE OF A STOIC WOMAN
MADE ENTIRELY OF COPPER,
HOLDING A GOLDEN TORCH TO
REPRESENT LIBER--[chuckles]
[bleep].
THAT'S A TOUGH--
IT'S A TOUGH WORD.
- IT IS.
- LIBERTY.
- YEAH.
- SO BARTHOLDI HAS
A SIT-DOWN WITH CONGRESS.
THE FRENCH PEOPLE WANT
TO GIVE YOU A GIANT STATUE.
LIKE, GIANT.
AND WHENEVER PEOPLE COME INTO
THE PORT OF NEW YORK HARBOR,
THE FIRST THING
THEY'RE GONNA SEE IS,
LIKE, LIKE,
A-A-A 300-FOOT-HIGH STATUE.
AND THEY SAID,
EH, WE'RE GOOD.
I MEAN, THAT'S--
IT'S IN-[bleep]-SANE.
BARTHOLDI CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
I-I JUST WANT
TO GIVE YOU GUYS A GIFT.
LIKE, THIS IS--I'LL MAKE IT.
THE FRENCH WILL PAY FOR IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO [bleep].
AND CONGRESS SAID,
HERE'S THE THING,
YOU'RE FRENCH.
THE FRENCH
ARE KIND OF PUSSIES.
AND THE FRENCH
ARE KIND OF DICKS.
ARE KIND OF NOT AMERICANS.
SO BARTHOLDI
GOES BACK TO FRANCE.
HE'S LIKE, [bleep] THIS.
[bleep] AMERICA.
WHETHER THEY TAKE IT OR NOT
IS THEIR PROBLEM.
MY PROBLEM IS I NEED TO COMPLETE
A 300-FOOT COPPER STATUE.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO USE
THE BATHROOM AGAIN IN A SEC.
- DOESN'T IT SUCK HAVING A DICK?
- NO. NO.
- IT DOESN'T SUCK HAVING A DICK?
- I LOVE HAVING A DICK.
- [laughs]
- SO BY 1876,
THE 100-YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF THE UNITED STATES, ALL HE HAS
DONE IS AN ARM HOLDING A TORCH.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE LIKE, HOLY [bleep].
THIS IS [bleep] GREAT.
LIKE, I WONDER WHAT THIS
ENTIRE STATUE IS GONNA
LOOK LIKE WHEN IT'S DONE.
AND CONGRESS GOES, ALL RIGHT,
WE WILL ACCEPT YOUR GIFT.
BARTHOLDI IS OVER THE MOON.
OH, THIS IS SO GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE SHOULD PROBABLY
TALK ABOUT THE PEDESTAL.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT,
"PEDESTAL"?
I NEED A PEDESTAL
TO PUT MY STATUE ON.
AND THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS SAYS,
UM, [bleep] NO.
I'M NOT PAYING FOR [bleep].
BARTHOLDI IS FURIOUS.
I'M GOING THROUGH
ALL THIS TROUBLE,
AND YOU WON'T EVEN GIVE ME
A PLACE TO PUT MY STATUE?
AND CONGRESS SAYS,
THAT'S [bleep] RIGHT.
- I LOVE PLAY-DOH.
- THE THING IS--
HERE'S THE THING.
BARTHOLDI IS STILL BUILDING,
AND EVENTUALLY A STATUE IS DONE.
AND IT'S JUST SITTING HERE,
BUT THERE'S NOWHERE TO PUT IT.
[clatter]
- WATCH IT.
- WAS THAT EXPENSIVE,
[indistinct]?
IT'S AROUND THAT TIME THAT AN
AMERICAN NAMED JOSEPH PULITZER
STEPS IN AND SAYS,
THIS IS [bleep] CRAZY.
WE WON'T ACCEPT IT?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
ALL WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM
IS A PLACE TO PUT IT.
SO PULITZER MOUNTS
A TOTALLY NEW CAMPAIGN.
LOOK, [bleep] CONGRESS.
FORGET THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK WE SHOULD BUILD
THIS PEDESTAL.
IF YOU AGREE,
I WANT YOU TO GIVE SOME MONEY.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A LOT.
EVEN IF YOU GIVE A PENNY, I'LL
PRINT YOUR NAME IN MY NEWSPAPER.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
STEP UP ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
SENDING 5в, 10, 50в.
120,000 PEOPLE DONATE,
AND PULITZER'S GOING,
YEAH.
MY [bleep] NEWSPAPER.
AND EVENTUALLY THEY HAVE
THIS PEDESTAL BUILT.
- YOU KNOW WHAT
I USED TO DO AS A KID?
I LOVED EATING PLAY-DOH.
- DID YOU REALLY?
- OH, YEAH.
MM.
- THAT'S [bleep] TERRIBLE.
- [laughs]
- [gags]
I'M NOT EATING PLAY-DOH.
- [laughs]
- ARE YOU [bleep] KIDDING ME?
ANYWAYS, THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
IS UNVEILED
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH
BARTHOLDI ON THE TORCH BALCONY.
LIKE, LOOK AT THIS [bleep].
LOOK AT THIS [bleep]--
[gags]
OH, MY GOD.
- [laughs]
- [coughs]
- COME ON.
THAT'S THE [bleep] ARM.
- YOU CAN'T GET IT OUT
OF YOUR TEETH.
- [laughs]
- [spits]
STAY TUNED
FOR MORE DRUNK HISTORY.